[Música]
[Aplausos]
no hay decisiones sobre mí esta frase
que tiene un total como un parecido a
que no se aplica cuando las decisiones
sobre nuestra fácil
levanten la mano bien de ustedes ha ido
lo de un médico por un problema personal
o acompañando un familiar
parece ser una experiencia bastante
universal
levanten la mano ahora bien la sensación
en esta entrevista sería que se proponía
tenía más de una opción que había
alternativas
experiencias ya no es tan universal
pareciera que mucha gente se está
formando cuando vamos al médico
usted tiene que hacer esto usted tiene
que hacer lo otro usted tiene que tomar
el medicamento usted tiene que operar
de dónde viene el usted tiene y ha
sacado
que sabemos los médicos acerca de lo que
tienen que estar las personas
imagínense que tienen que tomar una
decisión
tiene que ser una pequeña reforma en su
casa llamaron al texto llama no muestra
marcha de obras y le dicen lo que
ustedes fijas
dos veces y tarde lo que ustedes quieren
hacer es tirar abajo de una columna
el arquitecto el maestro
porque si tiramos abajo la columna la
casa puede subir 6 años
ahora piensen que es la forma que
ustedes quieren hacer pueden hacer un
nuevo dormitorio o un patio y no son
técnicamente posibles
y el 30 cree que ustedes quieren
agrandar su familia entonces el
dormitorio sería una buena opción o
piensen que están pensando en adoptar
una mascota en cuyo caso el para quien
sería una mejor alternativa
quien mejor sabe si dormitorio comparte
hay una vital la casa
y él mismo está de qué es lo mejor para
así estar
después de un encuentro con un paciente
con un paciente habitual si es que los
pacientes habituales
muy bien en el señor para hacer un
control de salud eso que se llama no se
quedó médico palabra no me gusta
y entre las prácticas preventivas que
ofrecemos los médicos está la
posibilidad de intentar hacer prevención
cardiovascular es decir tratar de
prevenir ataques cardíacos
los médicos contamos con unas
herramientas que se denominan guías de
práctica clínica que nos dicen los
distintos cursos de acción ante las
distintas enfermedades
nos dice qué hacer cuando mexicana
cuando estudiar
y tenemos guías de prácticas viviendo
para hacer prevención cardiovascular
entonces utilizando esas guías también
podemos tratar de desestimar ante un
paciente particular cuál es la
probabilidad de pacientes como él
teniendo algún ataque cardíaco en el
futuro
por este pasión 15º
de calcular cuál era el mismo que tenía
de tener un evento en el 1
ardía un accidente vascular
si lo mostré a él
le mostré que podía tomar una medicación
o podía no tomarlas
le hemos traído en cuanto que disminuye
el riesgo de tener un futuro ataque
tardía con la medicación o sin ellas
y también de con people y sí con los
efectos a norteamérica
y el señor
decidió de acuerdo con sus valores con
lo que era importante para ellos que
preferían no tomarlo
al todo un tiempo lo bueno
y le digo cómo llevar y lo pregunto
porque meditación está tomando y me dice
está tomando la medicación que había
decidido junto conmigo no tomar
y porque está tomando en la meditación
es porque quiero del doctor y me dijo
que la tenía que tomo
es decir que el paciente que había
colmillo ha tomado una decisión en
conjunto que el travel sintonía con con
sus valores que eran no tomar la
medicación
la terminó tomando porque el control
médico le dijo
tenéis que tomar
tales desde un punto de vista de la
medicina convencional
el señor tomara la medicación era un
éxito porque esas guías de práctica
clínica que son y son de día que con el
nivel de riesgo pequeño el paciente el
paciente tenía indicaciones
pero permítanme desde mi perspectiva
esto compra casas
porque el paciente estaba tomando una
meditación
que voluntariamente haya decidido
un paciente hay dos extractos
es el médico que está en carrera de
diagnóstico
de los procesos de salud y enfermedad
pero hay otro experto que es el paciente
que es experto en sí mismo en que tiene
que no quiere a que le llame cuáles son
sus valores y cuáles son sus
preferencias
y lo que yo esté proponiendo en este
diálogo entre esos dos expertos surge la
mejor decisión
y que es la mejor decisión si hay para
este paciente en particular en este
contexto en particular
porque decirme con dar las gracias de
práctica clínica nos dicen a los médicos
cómo trasladar a pacientes como el que
tenemos adelante
pero no nos dicen nada acerca de cómo
tratar al paciente que tenemos
ya que surge estabilidad en la toma de
decisiones compartir
la toma de decisiones compartidas es ese
diálogo este proceso colaborativo en el
cual el médico explica las alternativas
por técnicas todas las condiciones
médicas hay más endulzó de acción
posible
militar operar
militar o esperar
y entonces del esclarecimiento de sus
posibles excusas de acción y el diálogo
con este otro estar también del paciente
debe surgir la organización
pues siempre estoy contando que son las
decisiones compartidas y déjenme
decirles cosas que no son
no son decisiones compartidas hacer lo
que quiere el paciente como sería en el
caso de el altet elite y la reforma
tirar abajo la columna
hay cosas que son dañinas que son
riesgosas
también muy bonita la información y
decirle al paciente está esta opción la
otra opción y dejarlo solo para tomar la
decisión
eso es un salto al vacío
y adonde este confunde con decisiones
compartidas no es compartidas
este el consentimiento informado
consentimiento informado se parece más a
un contrato de admisión en el por el
médico se tomó la decisión de que va a
estar con ese paciente
firmat a verificar los baños explica
todo lo que le puede pasar pero termina
diciendo final
es interesante porque cuando en el
ambiente médico yo hablo de estas cosas
de tomar las decisiones de manera
compartida
todos nosotros hacemos decisiones
y para el intermedio de inglés se dice
esto porque es políticamente correcto
sin embargo nosotros en nuestro grupo de
medicina cambiar del hospital italianos
pudimos hacer una investigación
y vimos 500 entrevistas de médicos de
familias que georgia estamos altamente
motivados para que este proceso de
decisiones compartidas ocurra
y vimos que esto sucedía en muy contadas
asia
como contraparte los médicos que decimos
y hacemos decisiones compartidas
a la hora de implementarlas ponemos un
montón de resistencias una de las cuales
es la información que hay que dar es muy
compleja hay que utilizarla no se puede
informar todos los pacientes
y yo creo que detrás de esta resistencia
hay una profunda construcción
paternalista de la relación entre
médicos y pacientes y una
infantilización de las personas pensando
que no pueden tomar decisiones por sí
mismas
cuando empecé de la charla
no hay decisiones sobre missing
y te dije que era una frase que tenía el
sentido común
pero no sólo en salud tiene que ocurrir
que no haya decisiones sobre mí porque
es de sentido común porque a mí me gusta
por su aparición de sangre
como en muchos otros países
pero en particular más rápido de la
argentina y existe una ley que se conoce
como ley de derecho de los pacientes
y esta es la pista que los pacientes
tienen derecho a la información tiene el
directo conocer las alternativas
y dice una cosa
que los pacientes tienen derecho a
animarse a un tratamiento
y eso no tiene nivel de pimiento de la
atención
a mí personalmente me gustó esta frase
de negarse al tratamiento no me gusta
aunque entiendo que la ley haya
satisfacción porque si vamos a ser un
modelo de toma de decisiones compartidas
no existiría
porque el tratamiento
en esta idea de negativa el tratamiento
es usar de una posición de oposición
contrapunto pelea entre el médico y el
paciente
entonces para que quede claro si uno
pudiera mirar por el ojo de la cerradura
una entrevista entre un médico y un
paciente en el que está ocurriendo un
fenómeno de toma de decisiones
compartidas
civil
pero un médico que hace una pausa y dice
acá tenemos que tomar una decisión
lo hacen explícito tenemos que tomar una
decisión sobre el taxi
veríamos un médico que dice podemos
tomar este curso de acción hoy de otro
inclusive más ha ganado
teníamos un médico que dice los pros y
los contras de cada uso de acción y
trata de estimar con qué probabilidad
puede no comer esos productos y esos
fondos
pero son decisiones compartidas no irán
en formas
entonces lo que tiene que ocurrir
después de que el médico acepta pagos al
esclarecer los posibles cursos de acción
tiene que aparecer una pregunta claro
la pregunta que abre salta ligamento y
la llave de las decisiones compartidas
y esta pregunta es
y lo importante para usted
el médico tiene que preguntar y lo
importante para usted
entonces esa información empírica
que puede realizarse en el futuro que
puede tomarse otra decisión un poco más
allá
y entonces a veces me preguntan
en mi opinión que debiera ocurrir para
que este fenómeno de las decisiones
compartidas sean más generalizadas
y créame que el cambio cultural debiera
estar muy fuera
tan fuerte que hasta me atrevería a
decir que es un cambio de paradigma
y tendrían que ocurrir cosas a muchos
niveles desde estados afirmativo le
havre de las derechos de los pacientes
de manera que hay un rol del estado para
que esto ocurra
hay un nivel
y también tiene que ver
como como se mide la calidad de la
atención médica a los médicos se nos
mide a veces la calidad de cuán buenos
médicos somos en función de por ejemplo
si los pacientes con determinado riesgo
cardiovascular reciben salitrosas o no
las reciben y entonces si a mí me miren
la midad mía como profesional
por cuántas drogas prescribe en
determinada condición no voy a haber
algún estímulo para estas decisiones
y ese cambio cultural fuerte tiene que
ocurrir en el entrenamiento de los
médicos todos los que formamos médicos
en el grado de posgrado tenemos una
enorme responsable
los médicos nos tenemos que entrenar
el resto de las decisiones compartidas
en todos los pacientes las opciones que
tienen en conoce que cuentan las
ventajas y desventajas de manera
balancear de maneras integradas
y tenemos que entrenarnos en hacer esa
pregunta que parece tan sí
y lo importante para usted
y esto nosotros lo hacemos lo hacemos de
la universidad en esta universidad
formamos estudiantes de medicina
y también tiene posgrado y también
tienen como poderes
pero si me preguntan
pienso
el nivel más importante que podría
empujar definitivamente a que esto
ocurra
está en nosotros
en todos nosotros como pacientes
ciudadanos
como interesante porque en el ejercicio
que hiciste al principio de la jornada
ustedes dijeron que les era importante
que el médico que escuchara sofía
esto me da mucha esperanza de que estar
de vacaciones de manos
y entonces sobre esa idea que ustedes
tienen de qué les importa que el médico
escuche su opinión
yo le propongo que la próxima vez que
tengan una entrevista con un médico
de las tres preguntas
cuáles son mis opciones
cuáles son las ventajas y desventajas
que cada una de estas opciones
y ponen la probabilidad de que soporta
además tres preguntas pero además
existen entre el coro de la voz de
ustedes en la consulta y que se les
escuche que es lo importante para
ustedes
y ahí sí hombre ok
que no haya decisiones sobre mi film y
también va a ser cierto cuando se trata
de nuestra salud
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hanway